he was
what i don't like about the mandate is
we're targeting everybody and we're so
crazy just about the vaccine as if it's
the only treatment that's available
we're not gonna get out of this pandemic
if you only concentrate on the vaccine
you have to have all the tools you know
early treatment prophylaxis whatever you
know uh
give the message to everyone that you
know we focus on making people healthy
because if you're healthy the chances of
you dying from this disease is very low
it's over the top
and they're just not they're just
ignoring it it's just crazy so everybody
needs to have a personal choice
no
mandates at all for employers for
anybody for healthcare workers for
anybody and they need informed consent
they need to know what the risks are of
getting the disease and what the risks
are of getting the vaccine
[Music]
[Music]
why
so it's like booster now i'm not doing
no more you know what i mean i'm coming
out because i'm completely against
mandates i think they're unethical
i think
they're ineffective
and i think they're anti-constitutional
well i'm against the government telling
me that i have to have the vaccine i'm
not personally vaccinated don't plan on
being backstage right same for me like
we don't if you want to get it you're
more than welcome to but the government
should never tell me that i have to get
something
ever so that's more about what it is for
us like if you want to get it more power
to you do i think you should get it
probably not but i won't get it
[Music]
american american
[Music]
[Applause]
you